we're here with podma lakshmi and her
date view
children's book tomatoes for nila is out
now tell us all about it this is a labor
of love it's based on a story that i
used to tell my daughter krishna because
i realized she didn't know when anything
grew you know she doesn't live near a
farm or an orchard and if you're lucky
enough to go to a nice grocery store you
can find everything all year round yeah
so it's about teaching kids to eat
seasonally because if a child is aware
of the seasons in mother nature they're
better likely stewards when they grow
older of our planet and the environment
but it's also about cooking with your
family i believe that you should get
kids involved in cooking as early as
possible because giving the giving a
child early on the love of cooking and
the appreciation of good food will serve
them for the rest of their lives long
after we're gone and a kid that has a
hand in cooking their own food will be
more likely to eat it because they feel
a sense of pride
and proprietorship well and my daughters
and i
there's this beautiful double page
spread where you literally get into just
a perfect balance of global foods and so
we all sat around and picked our
favorites oh how nice all right well you
have two recipes in your book in the
back yes to help you get started cooking
with your family the reason i picked
tomatoes is because kids are so familiar
with them well and you're going to show
us some of the kid-friendly ways to
serve them so we wanted to get one of
our
favorite correspondents for the show
this is a true alumni we've worked with
him since day one it's the shirley
temple king himself leo kelly
hi
it is so nice to be back and it's nice
to meet you hi very nice to meet you leo
this looks so good
well and leo you read tomatoes for neila
um i'd love to hear a review
i personally loved the book i thought it
was so great and i also loved it because
i could relate to it because last week
me and my grandma and my great-grandma
made
canned tomato sauce look at that oh my
gosh that's great
i know
thank you
i'm also like jealous i want to be a
canner i gotta get on top of this i know
my goodness all right well padma tell us
about your tomato sauce from the book
here are all the ingredients for the
tomato sauce as you can see it's a very
simple recipe just
tomatoes garlic olive oil bay leaves
salt a pinch of sugar and maybe a little
red chili if you're into it but you
don't have to so the other recipe is for
a tomato chutney and that tray in front
of you drew has the ingredients for the
tomato chutney in it and it's very easy
to do as well
so the basic tomato sauce is great on
pasta we've used it today as
a pizza sauce as well as pasta so i
would like you leo to try the pasta and
tell me what you think okay for sure i'm
just going to try it along with you leo
just but you can you can try it too i
got to get a pod for what you think i
gotta get the perfect bite
you know
it's so exciting after your romantic
writing through the book to actually
taste what it tastes like
leo what do you think
i think
that is so good the tomato sauce is
sweet the spaghetti is amazing and the
meatball is a really good meatball
yay
all right don't put your fork back in
there because it dropped on the floor
[Applause]
sorry
we'll get you another fork but why don't
you taste the pizza and tell me how the
sauce oh yeah sure i'll taste the pizza
yes
heavenly
leo what do you think
it's indescribable
it's amazing
i have to say too you know you think of
pizza and pasta oh i noticed there's a
grilled cheese here to dip in um that
has the chutney in it yes so
the chutney is wonderful you can use it
um in in place of salsa with chips which
we have here too
you can use it to dip grilled cheese
sandwiches into all right
i think you can tell that i'm loving
this tomato sauce
i love everything about you leo
thank you what is your favorite food
right now the pizza i like pizza can
actually in fact
if any extra pies are backstage just
give them to me
you got it all right the new episodes of
taste the nation
premiere in november really quickly also
i know that the episodes you have are
holiday themed and would you quickly
tell me about those because reading
about them i was like once again you've
just nailed it
well uh they are a series of specials
that center around the holidays uh so we
look at ashkenazi jewish people
who originated in the lower east side of
new york city in this country so we do
hanukkah with them and all the foods of
hanukkah and then we do christmas in
miami we do noche buena which is a huge
pig roast
that happens on
christmas eve then we go to
cape cod and rhode island to find out
who those original americans were
that uh western european colonialists
came to this country and met on that you
know first famous thanksgiving so you
know we look at who they are independent
of that thanksgiving myth and bust a few
myths along the way they they have been
on this land for 12 000 years it is
actually their land um so and that is my
favorite episode we also have korean new
year that we celebrate in k-town in l.a
which was a lot of fun and a lot of
eating a lot of eating i love eating me
too leo and i love you and i love you
and thank you
loves me and leo kelly as always
tomatoes for nila is in stores now and
tastes nation returns november 4th on
hulu
[Music]